[Music]
all right uh if you're here watching
this interview
this is my one warning make sure you
watch the first three episodes of season
four and then come back to this
interview
as we're gonna talk spoilers i'm really
excited today because i am
joined by sam yagar aka mark how you
doing today sam
good man how you doing i'm doing great
i'm just blown away by these first three
episodes and as always you come in
with the screen time you have you always
crush it uh but the question i think
that's on everybody's minds about
um mark here is that even in season four
this man
really doesn't want to give up on serena
can you give us kind of an idea of why
why doesn't he just call it a day and
move on from her
right i think
all he knew of serena was what happened
before gilead
there's one episode in season one that's
the only season i
uh the only episode i watched of the
show other than the pilot that i was a
fan of before
joining on the show that showed who she
was before gilead
and she was this just
a passionate uh compassionate dynamic
woman who had all of these causes that
she was a part of
and um and i think he fell in love with
who she was
before gilead and and still believes
that that's
in her you know that he i think he's
trying to will
himself to believe that she's um
that she's capable of good you know and
when you say that word love do you mean
like a friendly love or do you think he
has like
some feelings there for serena oh sure i
think there are feelings there
okay i think yeah i think he
i think he admires her i think he also
knows that there's some kind of
attraction between the two of them
and i think that he
i think he knows that they both enjoy
trying to play each other
right that's um you know that's not a
healthy relationship
but it's you know we don't always
go for the healthiest relationships do
we no yeah
it's life and um that's interesting too
and you know what's great is you've had
already a large and successful career
but when you got cast on handmaid's tale
was it like a different level did like
you notice more people notice you out
and about or did you know it's like your
follower account go up
no i mean i don't really uh i'm not on
social media so i i just um
i go through the world pretending i'm
not a celebrity and then when somebody
mentions hey
i saw you on that i think oh oh yeah
great cool did you like it awesome
um you know in handmaid's tale i just uh
you know i'm such a fan of the way it's
done you know i get to be a fan of the
show
um you know so that's uh i just kind of
feel like i have a front row seat at it
as a fan myself
no that's awesome man that's cool to
hear like how humble you are and
um speaking of just watching other shows
or not watching shows is there
any characters from other like tv or
films that kind of inspired your
portrayal of the character of mark
uh not necessarily characters from other
shows i just think it's um
it's it's what they i try and i try and
focus first on what
what the creators what they want you
know and there's
very little that mark lets on even in
the words he chooses
you know he he chooses very
um safe words
in communicating with anybody and so
to me i thought okay well he's going to
do his job better than anyone
that's what he's he and he's going to
try and navigate all these dynamics
um for for the cause that he thinks is
right
which is you know freeing the world from
gilead i think
um but we get to see how how dicey that
situation is the more these
characters come to play um and need
something from him in season four here
no 100 and it's really exciting to see
and
even like talking all this handmaid's
tell you besides that like
you know sam himself like this year
besides
acting like this crazy year we've been
in is there any other like
passions or hobbies you like to do to
kind of keep the time and keep yourself
just sane during
everything no it's and this is the most
disappointing part
about about my time off i i wrote a
a screenplay that i'm gonna hopefully
shoot this
uh this fall in toronto before returning
to work for season five um if
hopefully they have me back um
even though that i that i that i have no
hobbies other than just
trying to tell stories you know i love
filmmaking and
you know um i i just don't have any um
you know most of my hobbies are like
listening to my kids talk about legos
or you know so i don't have much down
time but
uh um are there any things i should
watch or catch up on
i did i will say i caught up more on
film and television
in the last three months being
quarantined than i have in years past
so this is how far behind i am i'm i
i'm almost through season two of
breaking bad
oh man okay so make that number one yeah
finish that
i'll get there and then take it from
there yeah
i love it that's yeah that's amazing sam
and it's just
been awesome to have you join me today
and i'm excited to see
where this mark story goes this season
everybody make sure to check out the
handmaid's tale and hulu every wednesday
to see sam obviously kill it per usual
sam thank you so much for talking today
and i hope to talk to you in the future
thanks buddy thanks for having me good
talking with you
have a good one you too